NARRATOR: Egypt, Valley of the
Kings. November 4th,1922.
A young boy working for
a British excavation team
led by Howard Carter.
He's riding his
donkey home one night
when suddenly, the animal's
hoofs slips into a hole
below the sand.
Thinking he may have stumbled
upon the entrance to a tomb,
he rushes home
and alerts Carter.
[suspenseful music]
RAMY ROMANY: When
Howard Carter came in,
they dumped feverishly all the
way through the tomb, 72 steps
till they reached the sealed
door of the tomb, which
was right here.
He instantly made a hole into
the wall before destroying it.
And Howard Carter
peeked in and said,
and I quote, "I see wonderful
things," which was very true.
Right inside King Tut's tomb,
there were wonderful things.
This tomb was packed
with gold and treasures.
NARRATOR: Incredibly,
Howard Carter and his team
had unearthed the tomb
of King Tutankhamun.
To this day, it is
considered the best
preserved and most
intact tomb ever found
in the Valley of the Kings.
Although the excavation
team achieved
instant worldwide fame
for their discovery,
their triumph was short-lived.
During the opening of
the tomb of King Tut,
all the workers were
very wary, the Egyptians.
It is known that
ancient Egyptian tombs
have the curse of the pharaohs.
Whoever enters the
tomb first will die.
[suspenseful music]
NARRATOR: While most
Westerners involved
did not take the ancient
stories of a curse seriously,
the opening of King Tut's
tomb was almost immediately
followed by numerous tragedies,
some with eerie connections
to the alleged curse.
[suspenseful music]
Soon after the
opening of the tomb,
a messenger went to
the archaeologist
houses was Howard Carter.
He found Carter's beloved
canary in the mouth
of a cobra, which was the
symbolic snake of the pharaoh.
Later, we learned that
Lord Carnarvon himself was
a bit on the cheek by a
mosquito in the very same place
that King Tut, it turned
out, was also wounded.
He died within weeks of
a blood-borne disease
very mysteriously.
Howard Fields,
another archaeologist,
who came to the tomb, had his
home burned down and flooded.
And people began to
wonder if, in fact, this
was the curse of Tutankhamun.
[suspenseful music]
NARRATOR: No fewer
than seven deaths
have been associated with
the opening of the tomb,
the same number of lives
that Oak Island must claim,
according to the legend.
Could there really
have been a curse
protecting King Tut's tomb?
And if so, what was behind it?
Curses were a tool of
heka, the magical technology
that the Egyptians used
that they said was a gift
of their extraterrestrial gods.
This suggests that the
curse of the pharaohs
is an extraterrestrial force,
or perhaps, even technology
that the ancient
Egyptians were utilizing
to protect these tombs.
[suspenseful music]
NARRATOR: Is it
possible that some type
of extraterrestrial technology
was activated with the opening
of King Tut's Tomb?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and its further evidence point
to the so-called magic bricks
found at the tomb.
[suspenseful music]
In the tomb of
Tutankhamun was four bricks
in the four cardinal positions
with some magical spells
from chapter 151 of
the "Book of the Dead."
Spells of protecting the dead.
They believed in magic.
They believed in the
power of the words.
The word for them makes
power, makes protection.
[suspenseful music]
When we go over to
the Tibetan arena,
we see these prayer wheels.
And this is a very interesting
thing, because the priest
would actually go by.
And they would roll
these cylindrical drums
with their hands.
And they believe that the
simple rolling of the drum
would actually impress the words
upon the space around them.
They believed that space
was alive and intelligent.
So this suggest the
possibility that certain words
do, in a sense, become
imbued with a force.
That force may be something
that certain types
of extraterrestrial or
extradimensional beings
can actually access.
Is it possible that the
Egyptians were working
with extraterrestrials who
would, in fact, generate
these types of seemingly
magical phenomena in the event
that people tried to transgress
into these locations?